[Music]
we all have a story to tell
but what makes each one different
is not how the story ends but rather the
place where it begins
do you think that girl have a future why
the heck not you know she's a catholic
can you call me pearl
yes you know who you are your buddy from
belfast where everybody knows you
[Music]
the whole family looks great for you
be good son if you can't be good
be careful
[Music]
and that thought will keep you safe
we're looking to cleanse the community
you wouldn't want to be the old man out
in the street
talk to my family and i'll kill you
it was that our side had done all that
there is no our side in their side in
our street well there didn't used to be
anyway
[Music]
we're living in a civil war this is the
time to make a new start
my math says if we went across the water
we wouldn't understand the way we talk
shouldn't be a problem i've been married
to your granny for 50 years i've never
understood a word you said
what do you want
i want you and granny to come too
bloody religion that's a problem then
why are you sending us to church because
your girl didn't kill me if it didn't
we're not deaf back here
how could i leave belfast
everybody likes them and everybody looks
after them
belfast will still be here when you get
back
will you
i'm going nowhere you won't find me
the irish were born for leaving
otherwise the rest of the world will
have no pubs
i want you
you know who you are
wherever you go
and whatever
you become
that'll always be the truth
[Music]
be good son if you can't be good if you
can't be good be careful
[Music]
[Music]
you